starting with his birth on July 1 1899
in Princeton New Jersey his father Henry
Jones senior was a professor of medieval
studies and a strict disciplinarian who
taught him several languages and
instilled in him a love of history and
Archeology although his birth name was
Henry Walton Jones Jr he got the
nickname Indiana from his pet dog who
was also his best friend he later
adopted it as his professional name when
he became an archaeologist Jones had a
nomadic childhood traveling around the
world with his parents he visited many
countries and met many famous historical
figures such as Theodore Roosevelt Leo
Tolstoy Thomas Edison Pablo Picasso
Winston Churchill and Albert Schweitzer
in these younger years were featured in
the television series The Young
Adventures of Indiana Jones which aired
from 1992 to 1996. it depicts the
teenage and young adult years of Indiana
Jones from 1916 to 1920. the first four
films of the Indiana Jones franchise are
Raiders of the Lost Ark Indiana Jones
and the Temple of Doom Indiana Jones and
the Last Crusade and Indiana Jones in
the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull the
first three are set in the 1930s and the
last in the 1950s and they feature
Harrison Ford playing Indiana Jones